let me ask you about the Famine of the
30s yeah
do you think Ukraine in the Ukraine oh
yeah fun fun similar there are a lot of
the things you mentioned in the last few
sentences kind of echo through that part
of human history
Jesus no one knows about
well now I've just spent four weeks in
Ukraine oh yeah there's different parts
of the world that still even if they
don't know
they know yeah right they feel history
is runs in the blue
in some sense they had a famine at the
end of World War II and part of the
reason the Dutch farmers are so
unbelievably efficient and productive
is that the Dutch swore at the end of
World War II that that was not going to
happen again
and then they had to scrape land out of
the ocean
because Holland that's quite a country
it shouldn't even exist the fact that
it's the world's number two export you
know that's the world's number two
exporter of agriculture products Holland
it's like I don't think it's as big as
Massachusetts it's this little tiny
place it shouldn't even exist and they
want to put here's this here's the plan
let's put 30 percent of the farmers out
of business well the broader ecosystem
of Agriculture production in Holland is
six percent of their GDP now these
centralizing politicians think tell me
if I'm stupid about this
take an industry
you knock it back
by Fiat by 30 percent
now it runs on like a three percent
profit margin now you're going to kill
30 percent of it
how are you not going to bring the whole
thing down the whole farming ecosystem
down
how are you not going to impoverish the
Transport Systems how are you not going
to demolish the grocery stores
you can't take something like that and
pair it back by Fiat by 30 percent and
not kill it I I can't see how you can do
that I mean look what we did with the
covid lockdowns we broke the supply
chains I've tried buying something
lately
you can't and wait and aren't the
Chinese threatening Taiwan at the moment
what are we going to do without chips
so
I don't know what these people are
thinking and then I think okay what are
they thinking well the Deloitte people
are thinking aren't we smart and
shouldn't we be hired by our corporate
employers it's like okay
too bad about the poor
um what are the uh environmentalist
thinking we love the planet it's like do
you
we love the poor do you okay let's pit
the planet against the poor who wins the
planet okay you don't love the poor that
much do you love the planet
or do you hate capitalism let's pit
those two things against each other oh
well it turns out we actually hate
capitalism how can we tell
because you're willing to break it and
do you know what's going to happen so
what's going to happen in Sri Lanka with
these 20 million people who now have
nothing to eat
are they going to eat all the animals
are they going to burn all the firewood
their stockpiling firewood in Germany
it's like so is your environmental
globalist Utopia
gonna kill the poor and destroy the
planet and that's okay because we'll
wipe out capitalism okay yeah the the
dragon and the fear of the Dragon drives
ideologies some of which Can Build a
Better World some of which can destroy
that world